foreign
today we will take you through the
Hands-On lab demo of how you can
implement the movie recommendation
system before we start I hope the screen
is clearly visible and the audio is fine
if yes please type in yes if there are
any issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I'm repeating again before we start I
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
yeah until then let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
press that Bell icon to never miss any
update from Simply learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
press that Bell icon to never miss any
update from Simply learn
I can see the people start joining
great I think we can get started in
today's session we will go through what
is movie recommendation system after
that we will see how movie
recommendation system work moving
forward we will see filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system and at
the end we will see Hands-On lab demo
like how to create movie recommendation
system using python in detail we already
have data set with us we will perform
different function and Implement a movie
recommendation system using python
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is movie
recommendation system actually is and
proceed further for the same
so renting CDs and DVDs reading local TV
listenings watching film strip
projectors or recordings all of this is
a thing of the past today
all of the world's biggest film
collection have been digitized and moved
to the online streaming services like
Netflix HBO or YouTube
this platform can now help us with what
is possibly the most difficult task of
all choosing a movie they have been
enhanced with AI powered capabilities
well that is no longer a concern for you
it is final time for machine learning to
put its skills on display in the modern
cinematic landscape
to create Advanced predictive system for
True movie expert data scientists are
prepared to investigate our behavioral
patterns and those of movies
a movie recommendation system also known
as a movie recommender system uses
machine learning to predict or filter
user fill preferences based on their
prior decision and actions it is an
advanced filtration system that
anticipate the consumer in question
potential like selection for a domain
specific item a movie
so after seeing what is movie
recommendation system let's move forward
and see how movie recommendation system
actually works a movie recommendation
system fundamental idea is a pretty
straightforward every recommender system
primarily consists of two components
users and items user receive more
prediction from the system and the
actual movies are the products filtering
and predicting only the movies that a
matching user is most likely to wish to
see in the main objective of movie
recommendation system the user
information from the system database is
used by the ml algorithm for these
recommendation system
based on information from the past this
data is used to forecast the user in
questions behavior in the future
data should be handled by expert because
it is so crucial to ml projects
including the movie recommendation
system
after seeing how movie recommendation
system works let's see some filtration
strategies for movie recommendation
system
to assist user in finding the most
relevant films movie recommendation
system employ a variety of filtration
techniques and algorithm
the content-based filtering and the
collaborative filtering system
subcategories of the ml algorithm used
for the movie recommendations are the
most well liked ones
filtering based on content or content
based filtering a method of filtering
movies in a movie recommendation system
that makes advantage of the item's data
this information which is taken from the
just one user is quite important in this
case
this technique uses an ml algorithm to
suggest movies that are comparable to
the user's past choices
therefore the information about the
prior movie choices and likes just one
person is used to generate similarity in
content-based filtering
and the second one is collaborative
filtering as the name implies this
filtering technique is based on the
interaction between the relevant person
and the other user for the best outcomes
the system contrast and compare these
behaviors it combines the film choices
and users patterns of several people
like there are two types of
collaborative filtering algorithm the
first one is collaborative filtering
based on users the goal is to find
patterns in Target users and other
database users like movie preferences
and the second one is collaborative item
based filtering the fundamental idea
behind this is to find comparable
products products like movies that
Target users rate or interact with so
after seeing the filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system so here
is one question for you guys
I will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong I'm
repeating again so here is one question
for you guys I will give you one minute
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give your answer in
chat section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong
so the question is which is the best
language for machine learning
programming
which is the best language for machine
learning the first one is Java the
second one is python the third one is
our language and the fourth one is C
plus plus
so this is the question I am repeating
again which is the best language for
machine learning
so option one is Java second python R
language and C plus plus
so I'm starting timer of one minute just
type your answers in comment section or
in a chat section do let me know your
answers
please I want that everyone should
participate in this and make this live
session interesting
so I am starting timer
oh your time starts now
please guys do let me know your answers
in chat section or in you can comment
down
42 seconds to go
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
30 seconds more
which is the best language for machine
learning
you can give your answer to chat section
or you can comment
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong guys come on please I
want that everyone should participate in
this and make this live section
interesting
one guys five second more
one
yep time up
so time is over we will give reply those
who gave correct answer and those who
didn't give correct answer we will give
you a reply with the correct answer
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform movie recommendation
system using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select here new
new python file
so this is how jupyter notebook UI look
likes so at first we will import some
major libraries or python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP
so number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so here NPD NP is denoting numpy so we
will import the next Library
port
pandas
as
PD
this should be space yup
so
pandas is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structures and operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
time series so
so after importing libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write like
we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with us
the first one is credits
this one
and the second one is movies one
movies one so don't worry you can get
this data set link in the description
box so let me write
here
credits
let's go data frame equals to PD dot
read
underscore CSV
here you have to give your location of
the data set
edits
dot CSV
the second one is movies
let's go data frame
this is for movie data frame PD dot read
ESP
so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location movies
dot CSV
okay everything seems good
let me run this
yeah
so then
here PD is for the pandas Library read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and CSV is used for the type
of file which you want to read
so after this let's write code to see
the data set so we will write here
credits underscore DF
and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore
so this is our movie data set
so this is how our board data set look
like so here you can see three dots
this one and here also
this one
so we are unable to see our full data
set like what if we want like full a
4803 rows
so at that case
we can write here
PD Dot set
underscore option
okay
and here we will write display
dot Max
underscore columns
this
and here we will write none
same for the rows PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
underscore rows
okay
none
let's run this
so now if we will write credits
underscore DF
it is running yeah
so now you can see your full data set
like full credit data set with 4803 rows
or four eight zero two rows because
there is
this is starting from zero that's why so
what about movies data set
okay wait running
it is still running you can see here
so here you can see the full data set
movie data set with 4802 rows
or if you want to see only five top rows
so you can write here
credits underscore DF dot head
so by this
only five top rows so from head you we
can see our five top rows and if we will
use tail instead of head we can see our
last five rows so here let me do with
the movies one
DF Dot tail
yeah
so here you can see 4798 row four seven
nine and Del four eight zero two so we
tell we can see our last five rows
so moving forward let's merge the credit
data set to movie data set because if we
will combine them the confusion will be
less and at the end it will be better
for us so we will write here movies
underscore
equals to movies
underscore data frame and credits
underscore DF
on
it okay T is small I guess yeah perfect
Titan
so let me do something something like
this
okay
it is saying data frame object is not
callable
edits underscore DF
okay why because
we haven't wrote merge here
now it will work
yeah perfect it's working so data is
merged let's see the number of rows and
column using share function so now we
have only one so movies underscore DF
dot shape
okay let's run it 4809 and 2 3 23 but if
we see here like in movies data set so
in movies data set here here yeah yeah
there are 20 and in here we are four
columns in credit data set
so
like so you will be thinking that's why
not 24 why only 23 columns that is why
on title you can see here on title the
titles in both titles are same you can
see here
both titles are same
in both
okay let me show you like this okay
after Pirates of the Caribbean Spectra
and so on
here you can see after pirates of the
academy inspector and so on
so that is why on title written while
merging so title are same so moving
forward let's see our merged data set
so we will write only movies
underscore data frame dot head
yeah
so our data is merged you can see
the last cast crew movie ID yeah you can
see here movie ID title are the same
damage cast crew okay guys
let me give some more
for the better View
yeah
so you can see all Columns of credit
data set are added to movies one so
moving forward let's see another
function like
movies
underscore DF Dot info
so by this
yes you can see
so by this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information
so here you can see the all the
information is printed
okay
like columns name and the all null
values count and data types too like
this int object and
in which we are working most so after
this let's move forward and select some
main column in which you are working
most so we will write movies
underscore DF equals to movies
underscore DF
title
comma and another one is overview
okay why
okay here we have to get like this yeah
so here we have to write John R
Jonah is complete and we will work on
what keywords keywords are the main
keywords okay keywords then
it will cost
then we will
we will do recommendation with the crew
as well
okay
so by running this let me see
our data again with seven okay okay
there is one error okay this is movie
the movie idea Journal yeah not index
okay got it got it
why not genre
it's John Oates I guess
what it is it's Jonas
that's why
it's Jonas okay
yeah so let's see our data again with
seven columns so I will write so I will
write here movies underscore DF
dot head
here
so you can see only our we have like
movies ID same title overview joiners
keywords cash and crew only
so here you you can see the selected
columns okay so let's move forward and
once again let's see the info again like
movies
underscore TF Dot
invoice come with selected columns and
let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that four thousand eight zero three
values are filled or not so what we will
do it we will see how many missing
values are present there so
here we will write like movies
underscore DF dot is null
dot sum
not like this
yeah perfect
so the function data frame is null this
one is null dot sum dot sum Returns the
number of missing values in the data set
so here you can see overview have three
missing values
so what we can do is we can write here
movies
underscore DF
DF
Dot
drop n a
this
equals to
true
okay
we will run it with sayings okay words
documents
also true okay fine
and yeah it will not create an issue so
if you sat in place equals to true the
drop any method will modify your data
frame directly that means that if you
set in place equals to true the drop any
will drop all missing values from your
original data set let's move forward and
see
movies
underscore DF
Dot
duplicated
so the duplicate method returns a series
with true on false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so
here let me run this first
so here we are we are getting 0. y 0 so
if you are like thinking there is no
true or false return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without some
okay let me copy from here yeah and I
will run this so
here you can see
false false false in whole data set
so some will combine them and return you
a value at the end zero represent false
itself
so we need to not need this so we will
write something else
so moving forward let me write First
movies
underscore DF dot I location
0
dot Jonas
let me run this
so the ilog function this one ilock
function
first let me do something like this
it will go up okay huh
okay so from ilog function in Python is
defined in the pandas module that helps
us to select a specific row or column
from the data set
using the ilock method in Python we can
easily retrieve any particular value
from a row or column by using index
value so here zeroth position line is
coming
which is here you can see
so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this PSI
physician
this one science fiction yeah so this is
because I am giving here Jonah that is
why you can see here
see id28 name action name something
something like that okay
so
let's import something called ASG
abstract Syntax for tree
so this is one of the major Library
import AST
let me run this import is a class
defined is the AST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so
so an abstract syntax tree or just
syntax tree is a tree representation of
the of the abstract syntactic structure
of text written in a formal language
each node of the trade denotes a
construct occurring in the text
so let's convert some like literal to
object and append them so here I will
write Def
convert
obj object
like l
equals to
blank array
for I in
St Dot
turtle
bit
EV
Which object
okay
l dot append
return
here we are converting is like here is a
convert is a function and L is the array
to append by using for Loop we can
append them to name so let me write code
then I will explain like what is
happening so let me write full code so
movies
underscore TF
like
Donuts
okay
because your movies
Donuts
and then dot apply
what
so then movies underscore TF
then I will write keywords
let's do movies
underscore DF
keywords
lie
this code DF Dot
so if we will see our old data set in
that like we will see old data set in
that Joiner and that's keyword this
keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a message retrieving them so by
using AST Library we just convert them
to the normal one like title so got it
guys so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
abbreviating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
type of questions regarding any code or
something
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's convert cash to
and like same as previous way like like
this only so what we will do here we
will write f
convert
am
here I am using
so l equals to
counter equals to zero
St
dot literal
we
if counter
does not
equals to 3
then
l dot
Dot
dot append okay then here I have to
write I
to name
okay
counter
equals to 1.
if you want to write like count as
equals to counter plus one it is like
both the same
else
click
done
l
so let me run this let me run this
okay so after this small code we have to
assign the values like
we are doing it for Costner so movies
okay moves
let's go DF then cast
there's two movies
underscore DF
asked
Dot
reply
convert
everything seems good
so let's see the changes are visible or
not so we will write here movies
underscore TF
dot hat
you can ignore this like this is nothing
so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and journal so like
let's do for the crew too so like we are
converting you can say in a structured
way
so let's do for the crew one two
so let me put some
yeah
so here we will add depth like fetch
which is nothing like a function name as
director
obj
okay
colon l equals to
or i n s t Dot literal
obj
if
I
like top
equals to
we can hit director
so then
l dot append
l dot append
um
dot append to the same name
but
return
okay capital l
so we have to again write that movies
video
equals to movies
in crew
lie
h
just remember fetch director is a
function name let's see changes
so here I have to write movies then
press enter
so yeah crew is all set so
changes are visible and data is looking
good so what we
like if I want to see the first movie
Avatar overview this like this dot dot
dot so I have to write here
like movies
overview
Overview at zeroth place
oh yeah so this is a full overview of
avtar movie like let me read for this in
this 2017 Century uh paraplegic Marine
is dispatched and blah blah blah blah
and civilization
so moving forward that what we want to
recommend movie in the basis of overview
genre keyword cars so for that we need a
separate separate words like in the then
22nd century alone
so if you will see in other columns all
the words are separated but like here if
you will see all the words are separated
like action is subtracted Adventure is
updated fantasy it's separated
so
there is a long sentence in this this
one in the overview one there's a long
sentence
so it's difficult to recommend from this
so what we are going to do is well we
will separate them like like other
columns so here we will write
movies
overview
let's do movies
and overview
and Dot apply
lie my bad sorry
then Lambda
colon x dot
split
error so let's see the results so movies
yeah you can see in the section so now
you can see all the words are separated
by comma so now it will easy to match
overview to recommend a particular movie
so moving forward so what we are going
to do is if there is a two word and
space between there so we are going to
remove that space so here you can see
science fiction are separate separate
okay so we are going to re like remove
this one this is space
so let's write code for that
so here I will write like
overview is already done so we will do
not do for that so let's write code for
the rest columns
so here I have to write
movies
like
genres
pursue movies
and again
Jonas
or apply
Lambda
X
I dot replace
to no space
oh it seems good
then I have to write for everywhere so
for I in x
it's for I in x 4 I in x
movies genres equals to movie genres dot
apply Lambda X
I dot replace this to this for
same score
so let's copy paste this see
one for keywords and one for cast and
crew
eats
I would
ask
first
that you
that's the same so let me run this
okay no error seems good so let's see
the changes so movies
so now you can see the science fiction
space is gone like here is science
fiction space is there
now science fiction space is gone
so like okay
let's move forward and create one new
column name as tag and put all the
column data in a particular column
okay let me do first yeah let me write
movies
this is a column one column name equals
to movies
then first we will put overview
Plus movies
and joiners
and movies
and what we have to give uh keywords
keywords
then again
movies
then
asked
let me run this
okay
so let's see the data frame movies
okay still coming so like there is one
problem I guess
yeah no no no
so here you can see all the data is
merged in a under attack column yes you
can see like in the second sensory blah
blah blah so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code
or anything just put as in comment or
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution okay so I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or like any
question just put as in comment our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution
so from here let's create a new data
frame
okay
so let me create new data frame because
now we don't need this overview car
screw Joiner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like attack column so we will
write here new
DF equals to movies
so
like movies we need movie ID
new data frame we need movie ID comma we
need Title
and we have everything in tag column tax
column so we need tax column
okay let's run this let's see our new
data frame
so this is our new data look likes with
only three columns like a movie ID title
and tags so here you can see array
brackets like this this area brackets
so
we are gonna remove them so we will do
what we will write here we will write
new
data frame
that n tags
equals to
new
data frame
tax
dot apply
Lambda
X
then I will give space
dot join
themes good everything is okay okay fine
yeah
so let's see the results so
we will write a new underscore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the zeroth index in tag column like
this dot dot in this
okay for that we have to write here
a new
data frame
tax
we did it before like for the overview
one so you have to yeah
so this is the whole data in the first
like first index zeroth index so some
part of the overview like from
civilization and some are you can see
this action Advantage fantasy science
fiction these are some like genres
and
like here you can see like these are
some Crews members
and
yeah like Sam Worthington like they are
some cast crew okay
so like moving forward like what we are
going to do is just make them in lower
case for the better prediction like
something in capital and something like
smaller so let's make it to
lowercase so new underscore DF
tax
equals to new
underscore DF
tax
dot apply
it's got an X
dot lower
okay
so don't worry about this error
let's see the result uh new underscore
DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in small case or you can say
lowercase moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so let's let me write first
from SK learn
Dot feature
Direction
feature extraction okay cool
dot text
import
count
riser
TV equals to
count
riser
underscore
features
features
equals to
5000.
oh
words
equals to
English
and this yeah
so count vectorizer okay there is a
I cannot import count vectorizer from
SQL and from user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital
okay guys so he V is capital yeah so no
error so count vectorizer is a great
tool provided by the scikit-learn
library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count
of each word that occurs in the entire
text so
let me write something CV Dot
with underscore
transform
f
X like dot to array
shape
okay
so the fit method like learns a
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are words separated by spaces and
like punctuation so that Maps each
single token to a position in the output
back Trace so here CVS are like here CV
is a counter vectorizer so let's convert
into Vector to array so for this we have
to write vectors
vectors equals to CV dot fit
okay then transform
X
in
so here we have to write
Dot
to array
yeah then we have to write
vector
its vectors
yeah you can see Vector 2 array all the
zeros
okay so moving forward let's get the
feature Name by writing
okay so we will write here
Lian LAN
CV dot get
feature
names
okay then bracket
yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code whatever it is so
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so let's import some major Library which
is import
nltk
so what is nltk the natural language
toolkit nltk is a platform used for
building python programs that work with
human language
for applying in a statical network
language processing NLP it contain text
processing libraries for tokenization
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning
so moving forward like from let me write
first from
and
nltk
dot stem
dot Porter
import
ER
yes equals to
order
I mean is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
or to the roots of words known as Alama
stemming is important in natural
language understanding nlu and natural
language processing NLP
so here like I have to write
so here I will write def stem
to text
y
equals to
or
I in
text Dot split
y Dot append
s dot stem
done
or join
y
so let's apply this timing to attack
column so here we will write new DF
X
equals to
new
if
tag
dot apply
them
so let's import a cosine similarity from
SK learn so we will write from SK learn
dot matrices
Dot pairwise
import
cosine
underscore see me clarity
okay it seemed good from SQL and
mattresses
metrics sorry Matrix Dot pairwise it is
[Music]
pairwise import cosine similarity okay
let's run this no error so cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two factors I repeat cosine
similarity measures a similarity between
two vectors of an inner product space it
is measured by the cosine of the angle
between two vectors and determines
whether two vectors are pointing in
roughly the same direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will write
cosine
underscore see me
clarity
vectors
so these all are the vector present
let's see the cosine similarity Vector
column and row using space
so here I will write cosine
let's go see similarity
vectors
dot shape
so it's still running you can see here
yeah
so 4806 rows and four eight zero six
columns are there let's assign variable
similarity to this
okay so let's similarity
will write like this it might equals to
cosine
similarity
this is underscore here
I did this because we don't have to
write always this long sentence a long
keyword you can say
so moving forward let's see First Column
like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
t
0
Dot
shape
4806 okay
so let's move forward and let's create
some like sorted list so
for that sorted
okay
paste
enumerate
spelling is fine
okay one more like similarity
similarity
zero
where I have to write reverse
equals to true
comma key
equals to Lambda
colon
X not capital x x
to write 1
one colon six
seems good yeah
so the enumerate function in Python
converts a data collection object into
an enumerate object enumerate returns an
object that contains a counter as a key
for each value with an object making
item within a collection easier to
access so finally let's create the
recommend function to check the movie
recommendation system
okay
so
so let's write here d f
recommend
we
X
also new
DF
in the TF
I tell
equals equals to movie
X
zero
tenses
versus similarity
and movie
yeah so movies
list
equals to sorted
list
numerate
red
distances
comma reverse
pursue
true
keyword
sorry key only okay
equals to Lambda
let's call an X
1
.
6
or I in movies
list
Dot ilock
I
0
dot title we because we need Title only
so yeah it seems good okay
so finally that like time is game
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can comment in the chat
section so I can check
so let me write first recommend
recommend for movie
Avatar
okay
so here you can see the recommendation
system is working fine so Titan a DOT e
small soldier Independence Day are the
recommendation for the movie after so
let me check for the another one
recommend
like for
one of my favorite movie Iron Man
so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron Man
3 Avengers Age of Ultron Captain America
and the Avengers are just
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
Liars
liar
things going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is
Captain America Civil War
let me copy from here only
yeah you can see the Captain America the
First Avenger the Winter Soldier Iron
Man 3 age of ultron's The Avengers
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code or question just put
us in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution I hope
you guys must have understood the
concept of how movie recommendation work
and how we can implement it using python
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
respond you as soon as possible and if
you want this full code if you want this
full code this full code if you want
so just comment for the same we will go
through the what is sentimental analysis
after that we will see types of
sentiment and Analysis we will see some
application of sentiment analysis and at
the end we will see Hands-On lab demo
like how to implement sentiment analysis
using python in detail we already have
Amazon Customer data set with us we will
perform different function and analyze
data for sentiment analysis using python
you can download data set from the
description box below so before we move
on the programming part let's discuss
what is sentiment analysis actually is
and proceed further for the same
intimate analysis sometimes known as
opinion mining is a technique used in
natural language processing NLP to
determine the emotional undertone of a
document this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept
text is mined for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
tools for sentiment analysis assist
businesses in extracting information
from unstructured unorganized language
found in online sources like emails blog
posts support tickets web chats forums
and comments algorithm use rule-based
automatic or hybrid technology to
replace manual data processing while
automatic system use machine learning to
learn from their data rule-based system
execute sentiment analysis using
predetermined
lexicon-based rules combining the two
method result in hybrid sentiment
analysis
sentiment analysis or opinion mining can
extract the subject opinion holder and
polarity or the degree of positivity and
negative
from the text and identify sentiment
additionally other Scopes including
document paragraph sentence and sub
sentence level can be used for sentiment
analysis after seeing what is sentiment
analysis let's discuss some types of
sentiment analysis so the first one is
fine grain sentiment analysis by
segmenting sentiment each phrase or
clause in a sentence is broken down and
examined in relationship to the others
simply said you can tell who review a
product and what topics a person is
specifically discuss in their feedback
and the second one is emotion detection
instead of identifying positivity and
negativity emotion detection recognized
particular emotions example could
include shock rage grief frustration and
happiness and the third one is intent
based analysis in addition to identify
opinions in a text the intent based
analysis also identifies behaviors
for instance a frustrated online comment
about changing a battery can motivate
customer care to get in touch to address
that particular problem
and the last one is expect based
analysis collects the precise component
that is being mentioned either favorably
or unfavorably
for instance a client May write in a
product review that the battery life is
too short the system will then respond
that the battery life is the main
complaint and not the product as a whole
so after seeing types of sentiment
analysis let's see some application of
sentiment analysis
organization can employ sentiment
analysis Technologies for a number of
purpose such as
determining brand popularity reputation
and awareness at a particular period or
overtime
customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target Market
and the fifth one is determining the
effectiveness of a marketing effort
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answers in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong so
the question is is text analytics also
refers to as text mining
I'm repeating again is text analytics
also refers to as text mining the
options are true
or false
so let us know your answer in comment
section below or in chat section
so I am starting timer of one minute
just type your answer in comment section
or in chat section
do let me know your answers so I'm
starting timer of one minute
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
so the question is is stacked Analytics
also refers to as text mining
35 seconds are left
do let me know your answers I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
the live session exciting
do one
20 seconds left
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so time up guys
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
okay now let's move to our programming
part to perform sentiment analysis using
Amazon Customer data set
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we'll write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
okay it's Jupiter notebook
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select
new python file
it's loading
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some bunch of
major libraries of python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
the first one is numpy so first I will
write numpy import numpy
that's NP
AI is a python Library used for working
with arrays it also has functions for
working in the domain of linear algebra
and matrices it is an open source
project and you can use it freely
numpy stands for numerical python
so the next one is pandas
so I will write here
import
pandas
as PD
so pandas is a software Library written
for a Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structures and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
after that we will import
nltk
so the natural language toolkit nltk is
a Python Programming environment for
creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing libraries
so after that
we will import from an ltk
Dot sentiment
dot Vader
import
sentiment
HD
analyzer
okay there is no column
yeah
so the Lexicon and rule-based sentiment
analysis tool Vader weather means
valence aware dictionary and essential
reasoning
is a customized precisely two sentiments
expressed on social media
Vader makes use of variety of a
sentiment lexicon is a collection of
lexical elements such as words
that are often classified as either
positive or negative depending on their
semantic orientation
Vader not only informs us of the
positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each score
so the next one is import
re
python re module fully supports regular
expression similar to those in Pearl if
a regular expression compilation or use
error occurs the re modules raises the
expression re
two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered so re means regular expressions
so the next one is
from
X blob
import
blob
okay
so a python two or three package called
text blob is used to process textual
data it offers a straightforward API to
explore typical natural language
processing NLP
tasks like part of speech tagging noun
phrase extraction sentiment analysis
classification translation and more
so the next one is
import
words
from
word
cloud
a word cloud commonly refers to as a tag
cloud is an image of words popular words
and phrases are highlighted using Cloud
creators depending on their frequency
and importance
they give you immediate straightforward
visual insights that can Inspire more
through analysis
and the next one is import
C bone
as
SNS
yeah
so like an open source python Library
based on matplotlib is called C bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization
where data frames and the pandas Library
c-bond function with ease
so the next one is import
matplotlib
Dot
Pi plot
as PLT
okay yeah seems good
for Python and its numerical expression
numpy matplotlib is a cross platform
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it presents
a strong open source substitute for
Matlab the API is for matplotlib allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications
and the next one is
import
links
c u f f l i n k s as
CF
perfect
another python module called cufflink
links plotly with pandas so that charts
can be easily created on data frames in
essence it function like a plugin
so next inline
at lordlib
add plot clip
so you can enable inline plotting by
using the magic function percentage
matplotlab inline which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below
the cell where you plotting commands are
entered similar to a Jupiter notebook it
offers back-end interactivity in front
ends so next we will import
what you can like we can import okay
from
Earthly dot offline
import
init underscore notebook
underscore mode
comma
a plot
okay
in it underscore notebook
notebook
mode
who gets through yeah
dot go
underscore offline
so
yeah in order to display the plot inside
the notebook you need to initiate
broadly notebook mode as follows like
this
keep rest of the script as it is like it
and run the notebook cell by pressing
you can shift press enter graph will be
displayed offline inside the notebook so
basically it is used for the offline
graphing you can see okay so next we
will import
um plotly
dot subplots subplots are important
import
make underscore
subplot
a yeah
the non-leaf nodes in this figure schema
are represented by a hierarchy of python
classes that was automatically
constructed and is found in the plotly
dot graph objects which is normally
imported as go
these class instance are refers to as
graph object the plotly defined
fundamental classes
okay
so here we will import some like
warnings you can say
like to get not error
so we will import let me give a line
space
import
warning
warnings yeah
warnings
dot filter
warning
ignore
warnings dot one
and
this uh like will not show
and let me add something PD
dot set
option
display Dot Max underscore
plums
Gamepad import words from word cloud
okay there is an error let me check
what's the error
okay import
this
word cloud
from word cloud
capital
and W is also capital
here will be capital
that's it would be small only
from word cloud
okay my bad here one from word cloud
from word cloud
import word cloud
okay
yeah seems good
so wherever we
yeah or in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to display warning messages
utilize the wand
found in the warning module the python
built-in class inspection is a subclass
of the warning module which is used to
display warning messages import warnings
okay for seeing full data every single
columns like
okay there is error c bond
no modulus c bond so
s will be small
got it
okay inline
this only live
something like that in line
okay any errors no
I guess no error
okay
yeah for seeing full data like every
single Columns of PD so here we are
using this pd.set option
so we can use for it
so moving forward let's import data set
so for importing data set we will write
here
uh
like DF equals to PD Dot
read
CSV
okay
add data set name
so
so you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for that
let me run this
okay
so like here is PD is for pandas Library
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read
so let's see our data
so here I will write DF Dot hat
yeah
so
if you want to like if you want to see
top five rows of your data set you can
use head and if you want to uh like see
five rows of your data set you can use
tail insert instead of head this one
okay so this is our data set with only
five rows
if you want to see full data set you can
like from starting from 0 and ending it
four nine one four rows okay
four nine one one five rows and 12
columns
it
so let me give something like this for
the pattern visual
yeah
okay so moving ahead let's sort this
Wilson bound column to ascending order
for better analysis so I am talking
about this Wilson lower bound column
this one for it's not zero zero zero
like you know all the rows so let me
show you
so here you have to write like DF equals
to DF dot sort
values
Wilson
spelling should be correct
lower
pound
make it to ascending order
ascending
sorry descending order so
we have dot drop
named
unnamed
colon 0
okay
in place
and base equals to true
comma X is
equals to 1
okay so let's see our data
so here you can see the data is sorted
in as
in as ascending order okay
so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
draft method eliminate the specified
column when the column axis is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row axis is
supplied
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any queries or like any
queries regarding any code or there is
something questionable here just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
okay
so moving forward let's make a function
for missing values
so okay
foreign
so I will write here like DF
missing
values
analysis
okay it's def a function we use DF
columns
was true
col
for columns
for
col
n d f Dot
columns
DF
column
is null
dot sum
greater than zero
underscore Miss
equals to
DF
underscore columns
let's go
dot sum
but with DOT sort values
sort underscore values
like in ascending
ascending
ascending equals to
true
okay
like some
if you like this and this
that's fine I guess
yeah so here I will write ratio
underscore equals to
DF n a underscore columns
underscore
Dot
additional
same thing that sum
foreign
hundred
or sort
values
ending
was true true
fine
okay okay
that means okay and the TF part
that sort value is because you're
standing goes to True fine
so
here we will write missing
underscore DF equals to PD
Dot concat
V Dot round
issue
underscore comma
two
you're perfect
well access will be 1.
okay
is
equals to
that will give like
total where I will write missing values
missing
values
okay
comma ratio
underscore DF equals to PD
dot data frame
score DF
okay so let me return
OTF
let's create one more function for like
check data frame so DF
that underscore data frame
okay
it equals to five
comma tail
equals to
5.
so here I will write print
okay
yeah
Dot Center
comma
again for row Sprint
pose
belly braces
okay
dot format
s
what format
yeah
dot shape
you know
so for column Sprint
or shape
paint
and types like of types of data
Dot
Center
same as like that 82
comma
end
DF dot d types
Center
just printing this is like you will see
don't worry
just stay with me you will see the
beautiful result
yeah print
values
print missing values uh analysis uh
yeses like DF
okay
then again
get it
values
like there's many how many duplicate
values are there
so dot same for the center
gee
one more again this one
end
we have Dot duplicated
don't worry I will explain you like line
by line
just stay with me let me write the whole
code
first print
tiles
like I am printing multiple of things
so just be with me
Dot
82
comma
F Dot
one tile
zero five
comma
one
okay
check
data frame
I'm hoping like there will be no error
yeah
so you can see now like multiple
information regarding data set is
printed
so this shape is for like how many rows
and columns present in the data set
like in types you can say like every
column type like object
N64 float 64 and many more are like
present so like you can see review text
is like object and their differences in
N64 and Wilson lower bound is float 64.
okay so total missing values
so total missing values are like uh 1
from here and one from here like one in
from reviewer name and other is from
reviewer text
and like there is no duplicated values
in our data set
and here you can see so like after that
quantize a quantile defines a particular
part of the data set that is a quantile
determines how many values in the
distribution are above or below a
certain limit
special quantiles are the like quartile
quarter and you can say quintile that
the fifth one and the percentile which
is from 100th okay so quantile is for
like quarter
or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 83 82 and this for
this purpose
for making this something look cool
that is why
okay and
so moving forward
let's see unique values and in each
column
okay so I will add
check
Plus
frame
unique
f equals to PD
Dot data
a frame
variable
variable
the frame
columns comma
classes
colon
data frame
I
I will write like an unique
unique
u e
or
I in
data frame
Dot
columns
okay like and unique
you
or DF equals to
dot sort
values
classes
comma ascending
equals to
false
okay
and unique
underscore DF equals to n
unique
F dot reset
index
drop equals to
true
return
and unique
q-u-e and unique
let's go PF
check underscore class
which one DF
so let me run this first
yeah it's running you can see here
okay there is an error classes
okay
check class DF
is saying that
this is
kses Capital C is small
let me run now yeah
so here you can see the every column
having unique values are sorted in
descending order like review tags have
like more unique values so it come first
and then review your name review time
date difference Wilson lower bound score
average then goes to overall
okay moving forward let's do some
categorical variable analysis for
overall yes so this will be like amazing
something amazing is going to be
happened
so
constraints equals to so I am giving
here like some
color values so
B 3 4
d
2 2.
E B zero zero C
okay
so you can change you can like write
whatever you want color
s
mistake
right hashtag here
hashtag
three come on
let's see
it's done
0 C
9 to e b
yeah
EB 0
3
and then d
you like five right
okay so d f let's make function Okay
small d f
categorical
variable
okay
DF comma
column
categorical variable summary yeah
perfect
so let's make some figures so make
subplots
plots
rows
equals to
1
comma calls
equals to 2.
let me write from here like subplot
ALS
equals to
count plot
like one four percentage
percentage
okay
so specs speech
equals to
a like type
colon
colon
that's why
okay
come on
same type
colon here
domain
we got dot add
and then Trace
Dot
bar
one bar and one that pie chart okay
why
equals to DF
columns
column name
value
values Dot to list
4X you can click string
yeah Str
I
or I
in
yeah
column
name
dot value
Dot counts
index
text
equals to DF
Alum name
dot value
counts and then bracket
dot values
dot to list
okay
so for text
font
the size should be
14 is enough I guess
so column
UNESCO name
X position
so I'm doing for like making chart so
stay with me to see that amazing chart
okay
so show Legend
s to take
colors
goes to constraints
so these are the like colors so I'm
giving here value like very variable
name
because
constraints
comma line
equals to
let
hashtag
DB
e
6 e c
comma
perfect
one
Okay small
okay let me just like go over through
everything is correct or not for the
column name
will accounts index yeah it's fine
text equals to TF column name
dot value
counts
dot values
to to list okay
text font equals to take size then okay
14 size is enough
name equals to column name and text
position equals to auto
and show Legend false and Mark
detect like color equals to constant
okay fine line equals to color
and this yeah this okay
cool
o equals to one
comma column equals to one
that seems good
like for pie chart we will make figure
dot at
so this is done for the like line chart
not line chart that bar chart and this
I'm doing for the pie chart okay
Trace
go Dot
pi
f
columns
column name
is
values
goes to DF
again that column name
what value
count
s
and Dot values
text font
because you take
yeah size
I will prefer 18 is enough
position
like Auto is fine
so Legend
there's still no need of Legend false
m equals to column name
column name
let's do
like take
then colors
because you constants
will go to one
one column equals to two like in second
okay you will see and you will get to
know don't worry
so if we got dot update
layout
equals to
column
0.9
and 5
man
X
all right
should be on centered
then y anchor
we are on top
red equals to
tally
okay
I plot
figure
let me run this okay like
call equals to 2
now let's see the chart of like column
overall one so we will write here
categorical
okay
variable
variable
summary
and then data frame name DF
comma overall
okay let's run this
okay it's loading here
it's loading
yeah
you can see this is this is our bar plot
and this is our pie chart
so
like this is overall
uh from overall you can say that column
so like percentage
bar and that bar plot so this is how our
like pie chart and bar chart looks like
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any questions or any query
regarding any code
okay like any code any sort of code
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you at the correct
solution
so moving forward our goal is to rank
the com comments by the sentiment
analysis so we don't get hung up on the
other details I have sorted this data
set according to certain rules before so
moving forward we want to clean our data
so let's see the sample data for
cleaning
so DF Dot
review
text
okay dot
hat
let me run this so
so this is our sample data looks like so
let's see like data full data for this
okay let me see for
or this I guess okay
or like any particular row you can say I
can take okay
so I will write review
underscore example
example
equals to DF
Dot
review
text I will take a random two zero three
one I guess
Okay so
review
underscore example
so this is like at two zero three one
there is one review text
okay so in that the whole data is here
like uh like so my lovely wife bought me
a Samsung Galaxy Tab for father this is
this this like to find the exact model
number this is a long you know command
I got the this this it works like a
charm okay
so
after seeing this data what we're gonna
do is like we will clean it from
punctuation and numbers using regex
regex what regular expression okay so
here I will write
review underscore example
example okay
equals to re dot sub
and what I will do is
okay I will explain
don't worry
small rate
to capital a
to Z
okay
comma then space
comma G view underscore example
exam
but
sorry
yeah
review
so here we used re for regular
expression
okay and
so all the punctuation and numbers are
removed from particular data
so let me check first
okay this A to Z then A to Z okay fine
okay so like all the punctuation and
numbers are removed from particular data
I will now convert the texture to all
lowercase our machine learning algorithm
recognized words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lowercase so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with the
capital letter as a different one so
what I will do is
here I will write review
scample
sample
equals to G View
again example
dot lower
I will split it
split
okay
yeah example
so here you can see we have converted
all the words in the lowercase letter by
using lower function and why they are
coming in new lines because we are
splitting them using split function okay
if you see only did lowercase for single
row like we did for the like two zero I
guess two zero three one okay yeah so
let's make all rows same in lowercase so
I will write here RT
equals to Lambda
X
we will
Str
X
so DF
View
text
is capital text
DF
View
text
text
okay equals to DF
View
just
yeah dot lower
we have done
add
see all the data is in like lowercase
so I printed just top 10 rows and in
like in reviews text column all the are
in the lower case now so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or question till here like any code just
put as in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution and if
you need this full code you can comment
down below okay
so now the time has come to do sentiment
analysis because all the data is sorted
so what
will I write
let me do it little bit up
yeah
so I will write
from
yeah
from Vader
sentiment
dot Vader
equipment
report
sentiment
intensity
analyzer
if
polarity
subjectivity
is subjectivity
so DF
if you
text
dot apply
da
XT PD
dot series
text
blob
and again text
Dot
like sentiment
let me run for Loop for index
comma row
in DF
G View
text
but item
items
or you
intimate
density
analyzer
or polarity
scores
row
YouTube Let Me score
or neutral I will write score
a for positive
if
this is something crazy if negative is
greater than positive
then DF dot location
index
comma
demand
equals to
negative
negative
yes Dan
lcf
positive is greater than negative
then in this case
DF Dot
log
index
comma
sentiment
equals to
positive
P capital
else
e f dot LSC
X
intimate
let's do
neutral
okay
so like this is for sentiment analysis
and text block
this thing like text blob
this blob okay it's block
a text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive
or negative or neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1 the closer to one
the more positive the closer to zero is
more negative
okay let me run this it will take
a little bit time
because this sentiment okay it is
getting error
like model Panda has no attribute series
okay which one
text boxing
next sentiment
okay here what is the thing s is capital
let me run now
it is executing
like fade for a while wait
so it will take time to run because like
because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer
it take times
again sentiment intensity
analyzer okay spelling mistake again
y index index is not defined
sorry again
index
it will run I guess because everything
seems good
negative positive and this else
still loading so I have to wait like for
like two minutes more I guess
still loading guys
I take time
sentiment intensity analyzer
so let me tell you again sentiment
analysis like this text blob
text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity
so polarity indicates your mood that is
whether it is positive it is negative or
it is it will be neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1 the closer to one
the more
positive the closer to zero more
negative okay
I guess it's still
running
so
it will take time so let me write code
for that 20 interpretation I repeat
moving forward let's identify the 20
interpretation now we can include the
positive negative and neutral status of
the command
okay then DF
DF
sentiment
what's equals to
positive
ought
lose
Sun
lower
ending
equals to
false
yeah
dot head
it's five
if I will run it may
give errors to me because it's still
running
still running here it's still loading
so let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and neutral
Okay so
categorical
variable
summary
TF
event
yeah
it came like this because of this wait I
will tell you
yeah so here you can see the pie chart
distributed in negative positive and
neutral emotions okay or you can say
ratings and here you can see the bar
chart also
so
and
you can see the percentage distributed
in each like in positive negative and
neutral one so I hope you guys must
understood the concept of sentiment
analysis how we can implement it using
python if you have any queries you can
ask in the comment section below our
team will respond you as soon as
possible if you want this full code
just comment for the same today we will
take you through the hands of live demo
of how you can detect Parkinson's
disease using python
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
shoes do let us know in the chat section
so that we can resolve them so wait for
some more minutes to let other people
join until then let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press that Bell icon to never miss
any updates from Simply learn
okay great I think we can get started so
in today's session we will go through
the hands of lab demo of how you can
detect Parkinson's disease using machine
learning
we will perform different function and
analyze the data set using python to
find who has Parkinson's disease and who
has not using different different python
libraries
before we move on to the programming
part so here is one question for you
guys
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answer is given by you are
right or wrong
so the question is which of the
following character is used to give
single line comments in Python
option A
double slash option b hash option C star
option D slash star
let us know your answer in the chat
section
so I am starting the timer of one minute
you can just type your answer in the
comment section or in the chat section
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
let us know in Yarns in the chat section
foreign
characters used to give single line
comments in Python
double slash has star slash star
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this
each of the following characters is used
to give single line comments in Python
15 seconds remaining which of the
following characters used to give single
line commands in Python
one
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one now let's move to our
programming part to implement
prediction system of Parkinson's disease
so first we will open a command prompt
to write command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select a new python 3.
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a prediction
system of Parkinson's disease
so I will write here first I will rename
this
foreign
so I will write here
quote
numpy
as NP
and the second one is import
pandas as PD
and the next one is
from SQL
port
svm
then from
SK learn
dot matrix
import
accuracy
underscore then score
after that from
Escalon
Dot pre-processing
import
standard
scalar
and from
SK learn
dot model
underscore selection
port
train
underscore test
underscore split
then press enter yeah
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has function
for working in the domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python and the second version pandas
panda is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time series
Escalon the most effective and reliable
python machine learning library is
called sqln or scikit-learn through a
python consistency interface it offers a
variety of effective tools for statical
modeling and machine learning including
classification regression and many more
svm svmr utilized in web pages and
chosen detection phase identification
email Gene classification and
handwriting recognition
among other applications we utilize svm
in machine learning for some reason
including this
both classification and regression
linear and non-linear data are supported
sqln mattresses the sqln mattresses
module implements several laws score and
utility function to measure
classification performance
some matrices might require probability
estimate of the positive class
configuration value or binary decision
value
and the next one is accuracy score in
Python the accuracy score function of
the sqln matrices package calculates the
accuracy score for a set of predicted
labels against the true labels
SQL and pre-processing the SQL and
pre-processing package offers a number
of universal utility function and
Transformer classes to modify
unprocessed feature vectors into a
format better suited for the subsequent
estimators in general standardizing the
data set in advantages for learning
algorithm
then standard scalar each feature of
variable is scaled to unit variance once
standard scalar has its move this mean
this process is carried out
independently based on features since
standard scalar estimate the empirical
mean and standard deviation of each
feature if they are present in the data
set
and the last one is train test split
python train test split method divides
array or matrices into random sepsis
for the train and test set of data we
will import the train test split
function into our application as shown
import the drain test split variable
from the sqln model selection
so after importing major libraries let's
import data set
so for that we will write here
DF equals to
PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSV
then data set name
is
dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below so let's see our
data set now so here I will write DF
so this is how our data set looks like
with 195 rows and 24 columns
okay
so here you can see like we can't see
all the 195 rows okay like top five rows
and
so
here you can see the three dots
this three dot what if I want to see all
the 195 rows so for that I will write
here
Ed dot set
let's go option
let's play
dot Max
underscore columns
here I will write PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
rows
comma none
and here I will write the data set name
DF
yeah
so you can see now we are unable to see
the all the 195 rows
okay
all the 195 rows
so moving forward we will use head
function to see only top five rows
so first I will do like this
okay here I will write
DF dot head
so here you can see we can see only top
five rows of our data set
so
so basically head is used for showing
first five rows of the data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show last five rows of the data
set
so let's move forward and see
and using info function to see the
information about the data set so I will
write here DF dot info
yeah
so the data frame information is printed
by the info method the data includes the
total number of columns their labels
data kinds memory use raise index and
the number of cells in each column like
non-null values note that the info
method does not indeed print the
information
okay so we all know all the column names
and the data types so here you can see
these are the column names and non-null
values then data types
okay
yeah so moving forward let's see some
statical values using describe function
so for that I will write DF Dot describe
press enter yeah
so here you can see all the statical
values of every column like mean is
standard deviation count like 25 50 75
percent the maximum value of that
particular column okay for every column
so
moving forward let's see how many
columns and rows are present in the data
set using the shape function
for that I will write here
DF dot shape
so here you can see we have 195 rows and
24 columns present in our data set
okay like 190 it represents rows and
this represents columns okay
so moving forward we will see how many
null values are present in the data set
so for that we will write
DF dot is null
then dot sum
then press enter
is showing data frame objects here oh
sorry for that
this is is null
yeah then press enter yeah
so here you can see there is no null
values present in our data set no zero
zero Z all the zeros are here
so we can say this is a good data set
okay
so I will just
yeah so moving forwards we will
distribute our Target variable columns
okay
so for that I have to write here DF
status
status is our Target variable okay
Target column
dot value
underscore
counts
and press enter yeah
so here you can see zeros and ones like
147 ones and zeros are zero sorry 48 are
0.
so one means those who are affected by
the Parkinson and 0 means negative those
who are not affected by the Parkinson's
disease
so moving forward what we will do we
will group database on the target
variable okay so for that I have to
write here DF dot Group by
then status
dot mean
yeah
so here you can see that we group data
based on the target variable for each
column for each column
all the 24 columns okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code like any code till
here
so you can just put us in comments or
our team will surely provide you the
correct solution okay
so moving forward like we what we will
do we will separate features and Target
variable
so what we will do we will drop the two
columns like first one is name column
and the second one is status column and
in another variable we will put status
column
let's see
I have to write x equals to
at DF dot drop
then columns
equals to
first one is name
and the second one is
status
okay
comma X is equals to
1.
then in y
I will put
DF
status
so let's print X and Y
so I will print here
print
y here
yeah
so here you can see all the X values
and here you can see all these status
value like zeros and ones only
zeros and ones okay
let me do this yeah
so moving forward we will split data set
into training and testing using Trend
test split function
so for that we will write
X
underscore train
comma X
underscore test
comma
y underscore train
comma
y underscore test
also
train underscore test underscore split
comma y comma
test
underscore
size
was to 0.2
comma
random underscore State equals to 2.
yeah
so here what I did I split training and
testing data into 80 and 20 ratio eighty
percent for training data and twenty
percent for testing
in prediction like this is the best
ratio
so moving forward let's see how many
rows and columns are present in training
data and in testing data
so for that I have to write here print
dot shape
comma
X underscore train
dot shape
comma X underscore test dot shift
yeah
so here you can see
like in training and testing there are
22 columns why because we already
dropped two columns name and status
okay let me show you first
and we checked this before there are 24
columns okay
so now we have only 22 volumes why
because we dropped the name and the
status column
so X train has 156 rows this 156 rows
why this is 80 percent of 195. okay and
this is 20 of 195. this is training this
is testing
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code or any machine
learning topic and python so you what
you can do just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward what we will do we
will do data standardization okay
so the process of transforming data into
a standardized format so that user may
process and evaluate it is known as data
standardization
most businesses use data from a variety
of sources including databases data
warehouse Lakes cloud storage and
storage areas
okay so for that I will write SS equals
to
standard
killer
we all know what is standard scalar
yeah it's a press enter
so we use a standard scalar for it so I
will write here SS dot bit
then X underscore train SS means
standard scalar okay
don't confuse yeah so using standard
scalar we fit training data into it so
moving forward we will transform
training data and testing data using
standard scalar Library okay so I will
write here x underscore train
equals SS dot transform
let's go train
yeah
then X underscore test
equals to SS SS means standardscaler dot
transform
test
yeah then press enter
so transformation is done now let's see
our training and testing data for that I
will write here print
X underscore train
so this is our training data
and print
X underscore test
so this is our testing data okay
yeah so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or any machine
learning topic just put us in comments
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution so moving forward we
will train our model using svm method
svmr utilized in web pages intrusion
dissection page identification email
Gene classification and handwriting
recognition among other application we
utilize svms in machine learning for
some reason including this
okay so we will do model training using
like svm so I will write a model
equals to
svm dot SVC
that will write a kernel
question
linear
then press enter
okay
sqln.scm has no attribute SVC okay my
bad
C is capital
okay let me check
okay
K should be small
then press enter yeah now it's working
fine
so let's train svm with training data so
for that I will write here
model dot fit
X
underscore train
comma y underscore train then press
enter
yeah it's working fine
so moving forward what we will do we
will do model evaluation so for that I
have to write here x underscore
then train
underscore
prediction
equals to model Dot
predict
X underscore train
train underscore data
accuracy equals to accuracy
underscore score
y underscore train
and then
X underscore train
then
prediction
let me do one thing I have to write D
here
for the better understanding
yeah then press enter from this we what
we are doing we are doing prediction and
checking the accuracy of the model svm
so like we will check accuracy for both
training and testing data okay yeah so
let me check first print
curacy of
training
data
data
here I have to write train
underscore data
underscore
accuracy
press enter
so the accuracy of training data is
almost 89 percent like which is not a
bad number
so let's check accuracy of the testing
data
so for that I have to write here x
underscore test underscore prediction
equals to model
dot predict
then X
test underscore data
underscore accuracy
equals to accuracy
score
y underscore test
comma
X underscore test
prediction
yeah
so now let's see the accuracy of testing
data so for that type light print
accuracy of testing
data
test
code data underscore accuracy
so here you can see the accuracy of
testing data is almost 88 percent so
we're done with the model building and
the accuracy part so let's build
predictive system now okay for that
I will write
okay first let me do one thing yeah
so I will write here input
data
okay
then we will change data into numpy
array so for that we will write input
underscore data underscore NP equals to
NP dot as array
foreign
input
underscore data
okay
so now what we will do
we will reshape this array okay we will
reshape this numpy array for that I will
write input underscore
data
underscore for a shape I will write only
re
so input
underscore data
let's go NP
dot reshape
then
1 2
minus 1.
okay
so now we will standardize the data for
that I will write here s underscore data
equals to SS dot transform
input
underscore data
foreign
so now I will make prediction model
prediction equals to
model dot predict
the standardized digital so as data
so you have to print
Shen
so for that I have to write here if
if prediction
0 equals to equals to zero
okay
then it should be print print
negative
no
Parkinson's
okay
else
trend
positive
Parkinson
Parkinson's found
so we are done with the our coding part
so what we will do I will go on the my
data set
open with Notepad
so this is our data set okay we will put
any random value
like this value okay
yeah
put it here
so here you can see the status value to
the zero
so
0 means negative no Parkinson found it
should print no Parkinson found so what
I will do I will remove this to check
whether model is giving
the right answer or wrong
then press enter yeah
here you can see it printed Parkinson
found
so now we will check from the another
one
we'll take the random
we'll pick
this one
okay
I will remove this status value
then press enter
okay something error one error picture
okay okay okay
let me copy it again
the
then copy it again here
we'll remove this
and then press enter
yeah here you can see positive Parkinson
found because there is one status is one
so so you can see the results are coming
amazing and correct so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
so just put us in comments
just ignore this warning
okay
I hope you guys must understood the
concept of how we can detect Parkinson's
disease using machine learning
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
respond to you as soon as possible and
if you want this full code just comment
for the same today we will take you
through the hands of lab demo of how you
can Implement loan approval prediction
using python
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I'm repeating again before we start I
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started in
today's session we will go through what
is loan prediction system after that we
will move on to the hands of layer demo
to perform loan approvals prediction
system moving forward we will be using
different classification algorithms to
implement loan approval prediction
system
we already have a loan approval data set
which is we will perform different
functional libraries using python you
can download this data set from the
description box below
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is loan
prediction system first and proceed
further for the same a mechanism called
loan prediction system gives you a way
to apply for loans and receive
notification when they are approved in
accordance with the data provided by the
applicant the system notifies the
applicant of the loans available so here
is one question for you guys I will give
you one minute for this you can comment
or you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answer given
by you are right or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you I will give you one
minute for this you can comment or you
can give your answer in the chat section
so I can see if the answer is given by
you are right or wrong so the question
is which keyword is used for function in
Python language Option 1 python option
two def
Austin c f u and C option D Define
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below Okay so
I am starting off timer 1 minutes
type your answer in the comment section
or in the chat section do let me know
your answers please I kindly ask that
everyone take part in this to make this
live session exciting so I'm starting
the timer of one minute
which keyword is used for function in
Python language Option 1 function option
two def option C Punk option D Define
which keyword is used for function in
Python language
47 kin remaining
30 seconds let us know your answer in
the comment section below
this is the easy one which keyword is
used for function in Python language
function Dev Funk or Define
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this exciting
five second more
yeah after that allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to implement loan approval
prediction system
so first we will open a command prompt
to write a command to open Jupiter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
Python 3 file
so this is how the jupyter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us creating a loan approval
prediction system
so here I will write import
numpy
as NP
so Nampa is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the second one is
quote
pandas as PD panda is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis
in particular it offers data structure
and operations for manipulating
numerical tables and Time series
and the third one is import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
so Matt broadly Python scripts can be
used to create 2D graphs and plots using
the matplotlib pi module with features
to control line Styles font attributes
formatting access and other features it
offers a module called Pi plot that
makes things simple for plotting
so the fourth one is
import
C bone
s
and S
so C bone an open source python Library
based on matplotlip is called c-bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization with data frames and
the pandas Library C1 function with ease
so there is one more
like prom
Escalon
quote
svm
so after importing libraries let's move
forward and import data set so DF equals
to
PD dot read
underscore CSV
on
dot CSC
you can download this data set from the
description box below
so yeah
so data set is imported let's see our
data set so we will write DF dot head
here
yeah
here you can see we have data set of top
five rows so basically head is used for
showing first five rows of the data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show the last five rows of the
data set
so let's move forward and use info
function to see the information about
the data set
okay so here we will write DF dot info
so the data frame information is printed
by the info method the data includes the
total number of columns their labels
data kinds memory use range index and
the number of cells in each column that
is non-null values note that the info
method does indeed print the information
okay so here you can see loan ideas
object then this applicant income is N64
then co-applicant income is float
so normal values like this
so
we know all the columns names data types
and information let's move forward and
see missing values in the data set so
for that we will use here I will write
DF dot is null
then basis
dot sum
yeah dot sum the data set total number
of missing values is written via sum
Escape rows in the data set that have
missing values as a straightforward
solution for the missing value data
so we have missing values in loan ID 0
gender is 13 then loan amount is 22
self-employed is 32
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code so just put us in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or any question
related to python just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
moving forward we will create one more
column
that is loan amount log using loan
amount detail and then we will display a
histogram for that
okay so let me do first for the better
view I can do this
yeah
I will write here DF
tone
amount
let's go log
yeah
equals to NP
DOT log
if
now we will do DF
loan
amount underscore log
dot hist
for the histogram then pins I will take
20.
numpy.log
a mathematical function that helps user
to calculate natural logarithms of X
where X belongs to all the input error
elements you can see histograms it's
looking fine let's see the null values
in our new column
so I will write here
PF dot is null
dot sum
so here you can see in loan amount log
there are 22 missing values
so moving forward let's create one more
column name total income in this we will
add two columns applicant income and
co-applicant income and we will display
histogram for the same
EF like
total income
a equals to DF
applicant income
and we will add one more data from TF
that is
go applicant
f
total income
underscore log
pursue NP Dot
log
DF
capital
done
TF
well income
underscore log
dot hist
equals to 20.
yeah
so here you can see
histogram of the total income log moving
forward let's fill those null values in
all the respective columns
so here for that we will write
DF
gender
dot will any
DF
gender
dot mode
zero
comma in place
to true
and
what I will do I will copy from here
I change here gender to married
they're also married
and here for self employed
and I will do self
employed
before dependent
just everything will be same so here I
will add DF Dot
tone amount
equals to
DF Dot
loan amount
dot fill any
PF Dot
loan amount
dot mean
so here I will write instead of this I
will copy from here
and paste it here
yeah
School log
that Alice is small
so here I will write again that we can
take it from here
change column name
to loan
mount
um
on
amount
um
edit underscore history
gain
credit underscore
history
so here I will write DF Dot
is null
sum
it's it's worth giving error
same self employed
okay what the issue is that is capital
okay
again
dependent
okay
it's dependence
okay
yeah
so there is no missing values now
what we're gonna do is we will select
some specific columns and rows for the
training and testing
so for that I will write here
x equals to
dot I log
dot r
oh
in Colon 11
comma 13 colon 15.
dot values
y equals to
d f Dot
I lock
then colon command 12
Dot
values
let me see the X values
okay so mail no these are the X values
and let me see the Y values
okay so the I log function in Python is
defined in the pandas module that helps
us to select a specific row a column
from the data set using the ilock method
in Python we can easily retrieve any
particular value from our row or column
by using index values
so moving forward let's see the
percentage of missing genders from the
data set and we will do it for many
other columns
okay
so it if it will be 0 so it will be
great for us so we will write print
percent
of missing
gender
is
percent
to
f
sin
and we will write this
EF
and gender column
dot is null
dot sum
f
dot shape
zero
multiply by 100.
the same function object has no
attributes sum
okay why
because
here
percent of missing gender is zero great
so like so moving forward we will see
number of people who take loan as a
group by gender
okay so for that we will write print
numbers like of people
would take loan as
group
by gender
for that
print
DF
sender
dot value
counts
CNS dot count
plot
x equals to
sender
comma
data equals to DF
pellet
equals to
set one you can use either set two
either set three
so let me see okay so
here you can see like mail is 502 female
are one one two you can see the bar plot
so the number of observation in each
category bins are displayed using bars
using the count plot technique the
following parameters are accepted by the
procedure and are listed below this
parameter accepts optional variable
names for data or vector data inputs for
long form data plotting so moving
forward we will do for the same
like number of people who take a loan
Group by marital status
so what I will do I will just copy from
here
and I will change it to here
so I will write
metal
it does
and the guys who are married
here I have to write the
eight
so here you can see
like four zero one
the res like n213 I know
okay so moving forward we will see
number of people who tend loan Group by
dependents
so same what I will do I will paste it
here
I will just change the name here
dependent
change to here
so here you can see the dependence and
the Y label is the count so like 0r 360
102 101 and 51. and many more so moving
forward we will see number of people who
take loan group as a self-employed
okay for that what we have to do is
you have to just change names
e is capital here
okay let's see the graph so moving
forward we will see number of people who
take loan Group by loan amount
for that I have to write here
wait let me make a better visibility
yeah so
as a loan amount
[Music]
is capital
yeah
here you can see
paragraph
so at the end we will see the number of
people who take loan Group by the credit
history
okay so I will write here
same
as
credit history
that is history
edit underscore
history
okay
yeah so here you can see 525 and this 89
So based on my assessment we don't have
any missing values in the data set now
so moving forward let's import
scikit-learn library for training and
testing data set
so here I will write
from
sqln dot model
underscore
selection
port
train
underscore test underscore split
so I have like
train
comma X
test comma y
train comma y
test
okay
so here I will write
train
underscore test underscore split
is comma y
comma test
underscore size
equals to 0.2
random
state
equals to zero
on SK
learn
dot pre processing
processing
import
level
encoder
okay
so level
score x equals to
label
encoder
SK learn
but in my bed
X is not defined
here we have
is the one of the most robust library
for machine learning
it is open source and built upon numpy
sci-fi and matplotlib it provides a
range of tools of machine learning and
statical modeling
and train test split function of this SK
learn model selection package in Python
splits arrays or matrices into random
subsets for train and test data
and label encoder and code label with a
value between 0 and N class is -1 where
n is the number of distance label
moving forward let's fit and transfer
data for training
so here we will write for
I in
I in
range
0 comma five
X underscore train
comma I
equals to
label
encoder
underscore x dot fit
transform
and X underscore train
colon comma I
and X underscore train
seven
equals to
but
order
underscore X
dot fit
transform
and X underscore train
seven
let's see X underscore
oh sorry
train
and yeah this I
if this is capital X
with transform joins these two steps any
use for the initial fitting of the
parameter on the trading set
while also returning the transformed X
internally the transfer object just
calls first fit and then transform on
the same data
and we will
perform same for the Y
so
I have I will write here
table
encoder underscore y
EP so label
encoder
okay
Pi underscore chain
equals to label
encoder
underscore y Dot
bit
underscore transform
we see the results yeah
so training of the data set is done
let's do for same for this testing data
so I will write here for
I in
range
0
comma five
underscore test
I
equals to
label
order
underscore X
Dot fit underscore
transform
is underscore
test
of I
then again
X underscore test
column comma seven
equals to
label
encoder
underscore
Dot
fit
underscore transform
underscore
test
then colon comma seven
yeah and see the results X underscore
test
okay it seems good
all the values
so we will do for the same y test
so we will write here label
encoder
let me put
let's go y
equals to label
so y underscore test equals to
um
order
underscore y dot bit
score
transform
underscore test
let's see
okay
moving forward we will import standard
Scala for the further process
so for that we will write here
from sqlan
Dot preprocessing
port
Stan done
scalar
says equals to
like really assign this standard
I will do I will copy it from here
so X strain
equals to SS dot fifth
underscore transform
X underscore
trained
then X underscore test equals to SS Dot
bit
underscore transform
underscore test
okay skill and Dot preprocessing
okay sqlnp processing
standard scalar
okay sorry
and again like the standard okay
ER
yeah so standard scalar removes the mean
and scales each feature variable to unit
variance
this operation is performed feature wise
in an independent way everything is done
let's see which classifier is best for
prediction by seeing their accuracy
so for that
I will write here
let me do one thing
yeah
so like I will write from
you learn
dot ensemble
symbol yeah
import
random
Forest
classifier
so I will write if under
class clf classifier
equals to
random Forest
sorry my bad
so RF
underscore clf
dot fit
X underscore train
comma y underscore train
so I will write here from
SK LAN import
s
why underscore prediction
equals to RF underscore
classifier
dot predict
dot predict
X underscore test
so here I will print
accuracy
of Random
random Forest
classifier is
comma Matrix
it dot accuracy
score score
then y
underscore prediction
comma y underscore test
why underscore prediction
so let's see the prediction from the
using random Forest classifier
and the accuracy a random for it is a
meta estimator that employs averaging to
increase predicted accuracy and reduce
overfitting
if both type equals to true the size of
this subsample is determined by the max
sample argument otherwise each tree is
constructed using the entire data set
so here you can see the accuracy is like
78 percent
and here prediction you can see like
here one denotes that loan approved and
0 means loan will not approve
so accuracy is quite less so let's see
for another classification methods name
base
so here I will write from sqlan
port
gaussian
NB nav base
okay so NB classifier
plus two
gaussian
NB
B underscore classifier
equals to
sorry dot fit
strain
comma y
trained
so
a not equals to
like gaussian okay G's capital
sorry
so let's predict the value
y underscore predict
was to NB
a scope classifier
dot predict
X underscore
test
and print
accuracy
of
nav base
is
comma like Matrix
dot accuracy
score score
y underscore prediction
comma y underscore test accuracy of
gaussian NB is 0.8 means 82 percent
let's predict the value y predict
the prediction like one is like loan
approved and 0 is loan or not approved
so nav base is a classification
algorithm for binary two classes and
multi-classes classification problem it
is called name based the calculation of
the probabilities for each class as
simplified to make that calculation
tractable
so the accuracy is 82 percent and here
prediction you can see one denotes loan
approved and 0 means loan will not
approve so let's see for another
classification method like decision tree
classifier
for that I will write here
from
SK learn
dot tree
import
decision
tree
classifier
here I will write DT underscore
classifier
equals to
I will copy it from here
I will write here DT underscore clf
equals to
dot fit
X underscore train
comma y underscore train
y small
here I will
see the accuracy
pursue DT
underscore classifier
dot predict
underscore
test
so here I will print
accuracy of
dysentery is
comma Matrix
dot accuracy
underscore
underscore predict
comma y underscore test
so here you can see the accuracy is 70
percent
so let me predict
so decently the non-parametric
supervised learning approach used for
classification and regression
application
it is organized hierarchically as and
has a note root branches internal nodes
and Lead nodes this so the accuracy is
70 percent and here prediction you can
see one denotes the loan approved and 0
means
loan will not approve so let's do one
more classification we will do it from
the K neighbors using K Neighbors
over here we will write
from
kailan
Dot
burst
import
K Neighbors
pacifier
kn classifiers
we will assign
this
so here we will write KN underscore
classifier
Dot
fit
x and double strain
comma y underscore chain
okay SK learn
sorry
then again
okay it's Capital here
Capital here
yeah
so here I will see the accuracy
okay
my prediction equals to
k n
underscore classifier
Dot
predict
X underscore test
print
curacy
of
K neighbors is
Matrix
dot accuracy
score score
by underscore prediction
comma y
underscore test
so let's see the accuracy accuracy 79
percent and it is quite good so the K
numbers the five closed neighbors are
sought for the K numbers classifier the
classifier must be explicitly instructed
to utilize euclidean distance to
determine the proximity of nearby points
so the accuracy is 79 percent and here
prediction you can see one denotes the
loan approved and zero means loan will
not approve
so you can see
nav base
name is yeah so here you can see
we have name base classifier with the
best accuracy of 82 percent so we can
use it for the loan approval prediction
system
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code just put us in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
I hope you guys must have understood the
concept of how we can Implement loan
approval prediction system using python
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
shortly respond to you as soon as
possible and if you want this full code
and if you want this full code just
comment for the same thank you so much
for being here if you enjoyed this video
please do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here